we're going to continue our part two of
this our rapid speed run 10 minutes per
player
and um we're going to
and the point of that really is is and
i'm gonna i'm gonna finish my old
speeder and i'm 2300.
but obviously here we we have the the
luxury to
really spend a lot of time digging in
and uh we also have
the opportunity to review a lot of the
concepts that we
kind of said about in our main speed run
everybody ready notebook is out
[Music]
so 1300 we are playing
no chance ever thank you for the tier
one okay so we're going to play the
sicilian let's play the uh accelerated
dragon
um let's play the accelerated dragon
which i i highly recommend for players
in
sort of the 1300 rating range okay so
bishop c4
now we face this move a great deal of
times it's like the italian against the
sicilian but
uh that doesn't work that way and what
is the reason why this is not as good as
the italian
yeah the move is e6 blunting the bishop
right blunting the bishop
and potentially preparing d5 now
oh ho eva x taffy with 5 000
bits holy shoot oh my goodness
wow amazing amazing okay we're going to
the developer tonight thank you eva x
toffee
big time bomb holy smokes okay
so we didn't play d5 because that would
blend okay e5
now this is going to blow your guys
minds black to play there is a very cool
move and this move
actually becomes possible when there is
a bishop on c4 like very specifically
you need to associate
bishop on c4 with the possibility of
playing d5
after the game i will show uh
the opening where this happens most
frequently but there's actually many
different openings where this idea
manifests itself
so we're occupying the center now if he
takes my knight then we're going to take
his bishop and a very interesting pawn
structure arises there's a lot to unpack
there because for you guys you might be
looking at this okay great he takes so
you know this will not remain behind the
scenes now you guys might be looking at
this and saying wait a minute
double pawns ruined kingside pawn
structure like what's
good about this well if you look a
little bit deeper you guys know
that i always like to de-emphasize pawn
structure
or or rather put it in improper context
now what i want you to understand here
first of all it's hard for white to
develop his bishop
if white plays d3 then we take on d3
white is forced
to capture back and then the pawn on d3
is a sitting duck
second of all we have the two bishops
which in an open position is really good
one of these bishops is already like
pre-developed onto a really good square
and our pawns you could look at them and
say they're weak but i look at them and
i say well they're actually very strong
as i said they are stopping white's
white from really controlling any share
of the center
okay so c5 is being attacked how do we
defend this pawn
while also preparing to develop this
bishop beautiful nice job guys b6
killing two birds with one stone we want
to fianchetto the other bishop and at
the same time we're protecting our upon
queen to d5
also would have been possible by the way
just bro whoa
584 coming over from grandmaster's hands
and hamilton welcome guys
you coming a great time because we're
doing our 10-minute speed run
trying to pack this with instructional
content and this is just what we needed
somehow welcome everybody thank you so
much i'm on eric not sure who was
streaming
really appreciate it welcome chess bros
hope you guys stick around all right
so we're right in the middle of our
first speedrun game
let's jump right in really appreciate it
okay so as i mentioned many times
um it's important to be flexible in
chess right so
um you have to be able to change your
strategy at a moment's notice
but the funny thing is the move i
initially intended was bishop to a6 to
attack the pawn
does anybody see what's wrong with the
move bishop a6 thank you magno
and we're actually going to end up
playing bishop b7 here but
what is wrong with bishop a6 which looks
very natural it's queen a4 queen a4 kind
of forks these two undefended pieces and
the way you need to see this is
okay the knight is undefended you guys
know
that you have to be obsessed with
undefended pieces and when you put
another piece on an undefended square
that needs to set the alarm bells ring
so instead let's just play bishop b7 as
originally intended
then we're gonna castle and we can
potentially play night before and target
this weak pawn
okay so everything should be pretty
clear so far
um take a couple of bites of curry
okay what should we do now what should
we do now
so what is being threatened first of all
what is being threatened this knight d6
but we don't actually specifically need
to defend against knight e6
by castling we take the sting out of it
i like that expression taking this thing
out of it
we don't literally stop him from going
knight t6 but it's no longer a fork
it's no longer a fork we can reposition
our bishop to a6
and in the event of okay so knight g5
and this move looks scary it looks very
intimidating
looks like he's attacking us the reality
is um
if if we look very carefully at what it
is exactly that he's threatening we find
that uh his position has no leg to stand
on first of all we could go h6 but what
i want to make very clear
is we don't need to do that we can go
directly for the counter attack
now bishop takes b2 would be bad and
i'll talk about this after the game
basically the reason is cs queen h5
so we need to keep the bishop for
defensive purposes but that is enough
so if we wanted to counter-attack what
should we do
well we have to figure out what is weak
the d3 pawn is white's biggest weakness
right i think you guys would all agree
with that
so let's actually target that pawn if he
goes queen h5 which i think is quite
likely
what you guys will see is that his
position falls apart really really
quickly i take on d3 with check then i
easily disarm his attack
and then i win a piece um now knight d4
doesn't actually accomplish all that
much it doesn't threaten anything i like
knight before more it's more purposeful
if that makes sense um and
white is already in trouble because okay
so he castles which is correct
now what should we take on d3 with the
knight or the queen and both moves are
probably okay
um but let's actually annoy
let's annoy the crap out of him first
i'm going to go h6 i'm going to say get
out of here
then i'm going to take with the queen
actually it depends what he does
right if he moves his knight to f3 then
knight takes d3 actually attacks two
pieces at once it attacks the knight
which has now lost its defender
and it attacks the bishop so i don't
think he can save both pieces
but this is annoying because we're
basically showing
him who's best my guess is he's gonna
play this move if i
have the right read on his style that
doesn't actually work though and
we need to remember something i talked
about when i went over the greek gift
sacrifice to find the refutation
so when he goes it wait let's wait for
what he does because i don't want to
ramble on and on if he doesn't go queen
h but my guess is he went oh he goes
back
okay knight takes d3 right so does this
move make sense to everybody we are
attacking
the bishop and then the knight on e4 was
previously protected by the pawn
so now it has lost its defender so
there's a couple of ways that he can
temporarily save his piece
one of them is knight d6
counter-attacking my bishop that doesn't
actually work and we'll talk about it if
he plays it
uh let me write this down in case he
doesn't if he plays bishop to d6
then uh we still take the knight we'll
we're gonna have two pieces for a rook
and an extra pawn and we're gonna have
complete peace domination so we're to be
winning
although we're not going to be up in
peace hey it's easy no the first
speedrun is still on going i'm 2300 but
uh in parallel we're basically starting
a 10-minute speed run as well
or slower on as some purists speed-run
purists want to call it i'm fine with it
so everything i'm doing should make
perfect sense to you guys
and um white is completely lost there he
simply as i said he has no leg to stand
on
so the key thing that you guys should be
mulling over
okay so he literally gives us a menu
black caviar or
five guys or in and out five guys in and
out five guys in and outs uh
five guys five guys five guys because
the
rook on b1 is hanging it literally
doesn't matter we can take either piece
in and out is my california jam though
the reason i take with a bishop actually
okay so now we got to be a little bit
careful right
i know a lot of you are like wait a
second we can take the bishop no no
no slow down because he's attacking our
bishop
do we want to give up this beautiful
beast no no no no
we want to defend this bishop but we
don't just want to defend it
with any old move we want to defend it
in a way that also coordinates our the
maximum amount of pieces
now this is the habit that i want you
guys to get into right bishop g6 is fine
f5 is very good f5 defends the bishop of
the pawn
but even better is the move queen to d5
right
uh magic toaster very good because this
creates a battery against his knight
we are now kind of threatening to ruin
his pawn structure or force a queen
trade with a move bishop takes f3
we're connecting the rooks and and just
generally we're
we're solidifying our advantage if that
makes sense f5 is also good
and many roads lead to rome in such a
position so i don't want to make it seem
like i'm choosing the only winning move
or anything like that this is just one
way of approaching the position
black to play and win the game this as
some people said this seems to allow a
pin
but there's one very important tactical
detail
this is not a pin against the king the
knight literally is not paralyzed
and knight takes f4 is a very simple
move counter-attacking his queen if he
takes our queen then we take his with
check
even if it wasn't checked it would still
be good five guys
in and out this time we're going to give
some how much to in and out his position
is completely collapsed
he is down 480 million pieces and the
game is oh my goodness
we are just vacuum cleaner
is on vacuum cleaner is on
okay so let's walk over the game
so bishop c4 is is not amazing
but it's not terrible either so knight
f6 e5 d5 so
the opening where this happens most
famously is in the scotch gambit
and the scotch or the scotch italian
that's like a mixture of the scotch and
the italian
and after knight f6 e5 the move
d5 uh is the main theoretical
continuation ratings get refunded
uh does that make sense so this leads to
a very theoretical line
but basically that's the same exact
concept
okay so instead of d5 we can also go
after the pawn yeah so this is okay
uh we can actually try to win this bond
with this move queen c7 but i wanted to
illustrate the move d5
so he takes f6 now he should have
probably taken on passant
but then he's basically moved his epon
three times only to trade it for a
d-pawn that's only moved once
we have better control of the center
than he does and
uh this bishop we're gonna fianchetto so
this is a great position for black
all right if that makes sense i still
think you should have done that because
this position is already quite bad for
white
uh to recap some of the reasons that
white is worse here first of all look at
these puns they're doubled
but doubled pawns can actually operate
in tandem kind of like partners in
stopping white from controlling the
center
it's not easy for white to actually
attack either of these pawns if he goes
queen to e2 and he says all right i'm
going to win this pawn
well no no you're not because black can
counter attack this pawn and force the
queen back to d1
his position is just too passive to
allow him a sustained attack on these
pawns
so knight e4 b6 no problem defending
preparing to fianchetto
bishop a6 we didn't play because queen
a4 would basically attack these two
pieces and force the bishop back
well b3 is a well b3 is not possible
because that blunders the rook
so he can play against rogue b1 but like
nobody wants to make a move like that
maybe he should have so bishop b7 bishop
f4 castles
knight d6 is no longer scary now we can
reposition the bishop
and you guys might be like wait a second
isn't there queen a4
here we have to use the method of
comparison if we compare this position
to this position there's one key
difference black is already castled what
does that mean
that means the knight can move the
knight is no longer pinned
which in turn means that you can play
knight to b4 killing
everything in one fell swoop defending
the bishop
and preparing to capture d3 so method of
comparison very very important it allows
you to perceive
small differences in positions that may
look the same so he goes that fg5 we go
knight p4 ignore
now first of all this is pawn grabbing
right you want to be careful about
grabbing a pawn like this and
the problem with this move is the king
loses its defender
and queen h5 becomes devastating again
you have to use the method of comparison
queen h5 here black has a key defensive
move that he would not have
with the with the bishop not being on g7
actually there's two possibilities one
is h6
does anybody see the other defensive
option even more accurate than h6 what
else can black do
well not knight f4 because that that
blunder's the mate right
but before knight takes f4 you can do
what distracting move
no f6 doesn't defend against checkmate
bishop takes c4
good job guys defending the pawn knight
takes e4 and only now
knight takes f4 happens we're a piece up
do you guys want me to blow your mind
not only are we a piece up in this
position black to play has
forced checkmate beautiful idea and it
doesn't usually happen with a king being
on
f1 it's a freaking what is it
graco is right and it's a smothered mate
check
now we can take the knight and be two
pieces up but instead we give
smothered mate check check
this is the classic and 92 smothered
mate on g1 which is rare
normally some other made happens in the
corner but here it just so happens that
the rooks are positioned in this way
um and and this has been around for like
500 years this concept
sexy indeed so not necessary but very
sexy
and that is how you win the game so
knight before queen h5 is not dangerous
he castles we play h6 first first
we uh get rid of the knight now here
queen takes d3 would also be very good
uh this would also be very good it would
force a queen trade and we have amazing
pieces
and we're up a pawn but knight takes d3
just wins the game once again we have
two pieces hanging white cannot save
both of them
he decides to give up the knight and the
rest is very easy bishop d6 would be the
lesser evil at least he can get an
exchange for the
for the pieces but look at how amazing
our pieces are once we bring the rook in
everything is literally going to be in
the game
e4 okay so he plays the karo khan now
against the karo khan there's many
possible weapons
we play d4 one opening or one variation
of the karo for white that i've
recommended to charlie
very easy to learn and very good at
helping you build positional
understanding is actually
the exchange now here
the follow-up move to this is is just as
important as taking now where does the
bishop want to go like this bishop on c8
what would be its most active
development square
of course f5 exactly um
f5 is right d-chan by the way if i go
through concepts too fast please ask me
and i will
happily repeat them well g4 is hanging
right you can't go to g4 i'm literally
saying in this position and so bishop d3
is the move
if we make any other move then the
bishop comes out to f5 if we play knight
f3
then the bishop comes out to g4 yeah
literally decent that is the
point do not feel bad about that okay
and i will answer questions after the
game like questions about why i didn't
play xyz i will answer after the game so
here
a lot of people want to go knight f3 i
know
the problem with knight f3 what does the
night the move knight f3 allow in the
same spirit as bishop d3 we want to be
very careful about how we defend the
pawn
it allows the move bishop g4 but let's
not forget that this pawn is hanging
now i've already made this point many
times when you want to defend upon
the most solid way of defending a pawn
is generally to build a pawn chain
because when you defend a pawn with
another pawn that's just like very very
solid it's hard to get rid of a pawn
pawns are like very stable in their
position and so we play c3
now we want to get the knight out but
wait a second
as we discussed getting the night out
allows bishop g4 how do we prevent
bishop g4 in preparation for getting the
night out
bingo h3 h3 is correct
then we play knight f3 and this bishop
is going to have a very hard time
finding a good spot you can fianchetto
it but then it's kind of biting on
granite i already encountered this
problem with black
there is a way around this problem which
i will talk about after the game those
of you who watched my speedrun
uh you might remember how i solved this
problem there's a very interesting way
of developing this bishop on ca but it's
not intuitive it actually looks bad
that is actually to develop it to f5
which looks very bad okay so e6 is kind
of a
it's it's not a mistake but now this
bishop ends up in
a lot of trouble i'm just gonna castle
now in terms of developing this bishop
very important bishop g5
may look like the most active move but
bishop g5 is actually not very good
and the reason bishop g5 is not very
good is because this pin isn't really
dangerous
black can just move his queen away and
then the bishop is just staring into
open space
instead we should develop the bishop
more purposefully to f4
and the bottom line reason is that this
e5 score does everybody see that square
that clamping down on that square is
going to make it very hard for black to
untangle his pieces black is just going
to be very cramped
now we're going to develop his knight
the way to uncramp oneself if you are
black is potentially to get the e5
breakthrough which is exactly what a dta
is trying to do but guess what
that's why we developed our bishop to f4
now we need to pile up on this square
with everything that we have it's like
the intruders are trying to break down
the door
and we're freaking shoving everything
there we're shoving a door a picture
frame
they're not going to break the door down
so we're going to go rook to e1
right and queenie 2 would be
counterproductive
we don't need to play queen e2 we have
this defended enough
but here's the cool thing we can do on
the one hand
we can get pieces to control e5 but
there is another way to make e5 more
difficult
and that is to remove black species
which are controlling e5 now which
pieces are controlling e5
the first is the bishop hard to remove
the second is the knight
how can we remove this knight from c6
not bishop e5 guys
the problem with bishop b5 is that even
if you take the knight it'll just be
replaced by the other one and gay
hey this bishop on d3 is perfectly good
piece
b4 b5 use pawns
okay uh
so a4 let's go b4a4
does the logic make sense here
okay now the logic should make perfect
sense the logic should make perfect
sense we're trying to remove the knife
from c6 our entire game plan here
is to permanently prevent him from
liberating his position we're going to
just like
squeeze him to death now b5 uh doesn't
work because if a takes b5 this
is defended twice and attacked only once
okay mr lama
now here's the thing um before playing
b5
um there is a preliminary move that we
can make to improve our position in a
substantive way
now let's survey his position let's make
an inventory of his weaknesses when i
say weakness what should you be thinking
about you should be thinking about pawns
which we are making contact with and
which are not defended by any other puns
which pawn fits the bill if you are
white which of black's pawns
fits the bill of a weak pun bingo so in
addition to running him out of the gym
here we should be thinking about ways in
which we can pile up on the e6 pawn does
anybody see any maneuvers
which which can allow one of our minor
pieces because minor pieces
need to lead the attack otherwise we'll
never make any progress
which of which maneuver will allow us to
attack v6 bingo
knight b3 knight c5 right that is an
idea that we can implement as well
in parallel okay so he attacks the
bishop let's move it back
let's tuck it away on h2 maybe bishop g3
was better but it doesn't really matter
this actually is a very weakening move
okay so
this is actually a very instructive
mistake the problem with this
strategy for black is that he just
doesn't have this is going to backfire
he he doesn't have
the horsepower to to make this happen
and we actually don't need to do
anything about it we can just continue
along our strategy which means one move
actually sacking is interesting but oh
actually stacking is very interesting
wait a minute oh oh that's sexy no
that's actually the best move
oh man that's beautiful because look at
the queen good stuff
what you guys should see is that the
queen is x-raying h5
now normally i don't like to do this
kind of speculative stuff on the speed
run
but this is an exception we're gonna
play this daniel style knight takes g5
now after the game i will explain in
great detail
why this is good how i know this is good
but you guys should already kind of
sense
that black's king is going to get caught
in a massive storm
there's a couple of things to notice the
first is like most of black's pieces are
not very well developed
so black is not going to have the
defensive firepower
to defend against the attack the second
thing is
we're basically gonna have at the very
least okay so he doesn't take the knight
he doesn't take that he does go e5 which
which is admirable but it's just
a day late and a dollar short so
we're gonna play queen takes h5 let's
involve the queen we're still
offering up the night that that hasn't
changed now we're bringing
the queen into the attack the second
thing to remember
is that we have at the very least two
pawns for the piece okay so he goes z4
a lot going on here now when we're
attacking
um priority needs to be on
hunting down basically diagonals and
avenues toward our opponent's king
that's the best way i think to explain
it
and we need to do the wish list thing
again remember i was talking about the
wish list last time
the wish list is basically like what do
we really want to achieve now what i'm
looking at here is this king on jihad
and the first thing i'm checking for is
immediate checks
okay maybe queen h7 nah king of f8 if
you go queen f7 he goes king h8 i don't
see exactly how to continue the attack
but we're going to play knight d takes
e4 and if d takes c4
we can certainly take on e4 and involve
another piece but we have a much better
move you have to look at the whole board
if d takes e4 what do we do what new
avenues have opened up for our pieces
bingo
bishop c4 check king has to get to f8
and then we checkmate the king in one of
several ways and if he goes knight to d5
and covers it up look at the queen very
very carefully the queen is defending
the rook
but it's also gonna be defending the
night which means it's overloaded
we can take the knight and then we can
take the rook i'll show that after the
game
but i'm just sort of explaining the
logic here if he takes my other knight
we're just gonna take and we're gonna
have an overwhelming amount of pieces of
the attack
okay now we literally just need to
tear black's position apart
we nee and this is something that i
actually struggle to explain
this is tactics knight takes f6
there isn't always verbal logic
that explains a move like knight takes
it just works
i guess the verbal logic is that after
bishop takes f6 the bishop is
unprotected
which means that the move sorry the move
queen f7 check
is going to pick the bishop off with
checkmate to follow so we take the
bishop
and then then i'll exp so we go back to
f7 and now we have check made in two
moves
now this looks like it's checkmate but
whoa whoa whoa there's a bishop on f5 so
what do we do
very simple there's a bishop on f5 it's
preventing us from giving checkmate
we take the damn bishop and then we can
pre-move queen h7 he literally has no
way to stop it
nothing extraordinary right remove the
defender bingo
check me okay thank you
demon appreciate it thank you for all of
your support as well
so let's walk through the game so bishop
to d3 first of all okay
the idea to stop the bishop from
developing to f5
stop the bishop from developing to f5
knight c6 c3
once again knight f3 allows bishop g4
which is a very nice parking spot for
the bishop
uh pinning the knight and attacking d4
so we go c3
g6 being kettling the bishop now i
mentioned
during the game black's best setup so if
i were black here what would i do let me
flip the board for a second
so if i were playing black first of all
i would develop my knight in castle
okay well let's say that white develops
the bishop to f4
the move that i actually advocate for
here is bishop to f5 i played this
myself
in the main five minute speed run a
little bit earlier
and you guys might be looking at this
and sort of scratching your imaginary
beard and saying wait a second what is
this like you're weakening
the king side like this you're doubling
your pawns what are you doing
but i've explained the logic behind this
i think a couple days ago
because much like in the first speedrun
game we played today there's a couple of
extenuating circumstances here the first
thing is
look at these two pawns they are
clamping down on the e4 square
setting up a very nice little outpost
for that knight
now once you put that knight on the
outpost it's going to cover up any
attempts that white may have at getting
to the f5 pawn
you also have the move e6 which builds
up a little bit of
pawn chain and defends the weak pawn on
f5 the third thing
and this is something that i really want
people to pay attention to
the so-called weakness on the king side
can actually be used
in black's favor because the g-file is
sem it's what's called semi-open there's
pawns of only one color on the g
file and because it's a white pawn black
can use the g
file to his favor the plan is to go king
h8 rook g8
and to basically deliver checkmate down
the g file right
and these attacks that happen down the g
file can come really really fast because
black's pieces are essentially super
active
black species are like tremendously
active here and so they compensate for
these
visual defects in black's position does
that make sense to everybody
as we're moving on i'll run a little
chess-based search and see if i can show
you guys an example of a real game
where black uh conducted a successful
attack in a similar position if you just
give me a second here
1994 women's olympiad so watch what
happens
so we literally have the same line i
mean literally the exact line we're
talking about
here's knight e4 here comes the queen to
the g
file and here comes the rook to the g
file so literally these ideas right
get out of here and now sabirova doubles
her rooks
builds up alekhine's gut f4 look at the
pressure on the g3 pawn
and now what i love about this game
repeating moves
and now finding in this position a
really really strong
idea so this is like a damn girl idea
look at this pawn on g3 very carefully
we need to break through that pawn the
problem is that pawn is defended like a
million times
what resource do we need to involve
to just break that pawn down boom boom
look at this
look at the pressure on the pawn there's
four pieces on it
and white finally cracks five pieces on
it every single one of black's pieces
and basically even the knight indirectly
is is attacking that pawn and white
finally breaks knight takes f4 is a
blunder and knight takes f4 and hero
white resigned
and the reason white resigned is if gta
except f4 you get checkmated
what about rook takes f4 what's the idea
this is like a damn girl game
queen takes rook very simple tactic get
out of g3
and rook takes you to black ends up up a
rook in the end game
so there's other examples i could find
if i searched longer but hopefully this
gives you guys a little bit of context
as to how these attacks can get started
okay um so back to the speed run
yep yep yep that was a nice game
so that is the way that the black should
play now i'm not going to pretend that
white is like worse here
so the move e6 is i would say a
positional error
uh the chess related term
that you would use here is passive the
move well 94
eldar emily a good what exactly is 94
give us so the way you should think
about this
is in terms of understanding the center
so the center and chess is very
important when you have pieces in the
center
from a mathematical point of view you
literally control more squares
like the knight on e4 is like the glue
guy right it's gluing everything
together it's stopping white
from easily shifting pieces from one
side of the board to the other for
example if the knight was not
on e4 white would be able to go queen to
c2
and attack the pawn on f5 kind of
sniping at it
knight e4 stops that so you shouldn't
overthink it just like
visually speaking a piece in the center
like this particularly when it's
supported by several pawns
is like a bone in your opponent's throat
does that make sense
a little bit more sense emily
okay and don't be afraid to say no it's
fine if something doesn't make sense
that's my responsibility not
your fault that you don't get it it's my
responsibility to explain it in a way
that you do
okay so e6 the way to expl this is
passive right does it make sense that
this is passive
it should because the bishop on c8 now
has no prospects
bishop on c8 is basically confined
to a very you know fruitless existence
that doesn't mean black is losing here
but it does mean black's position is
very cramped
so basically we are now clamping down
on the e5 square with all that we've got
because the only way really to get this
bishop active again to get black's
position uncramped
is to prepare e5 and i like that you
played f6 but you basically have no
chance here because we've piled up on
the e5
square to such a degree that black is
just doesn't have the resources
necessary
to get that into the game okay
um so rook to e8 and now we go b4 now we
involve the queen side pawns we want to
go b5 and chase away the knight
what that does is it makes it even
harder for black even less likely that
black is going to go e5
in parallel we are developing the idea
of transferring our knight to c5 and
what that does
is it targets this very tender pawn on
e6 right
the reason it's tender is because uh is
because the pawn has moved out from f7
where it was defending it so pawns that
are not protected by other pawns
those are the ones that you should uh
you should be paying attention to
particularly ones on a semi-open file
right so we go a4 uh we reinforce the
threat of b5
g5 and h5 and this hastens black's
defeat and now the move knight takes g5
so i think by now most people should
understand the
zen of this sacrifice but there was one
key variation
that makes this uh go even better so f
takes g5 queen takes h5
we're threatening all sorts of things we
also want to bring this knight into the
game with knight f3 knight takes g5 but
black can try to intercept the bishop
with knight at five what does white do
in the event of this
why does this move not actually work
because also black wants to bring the
queen into the game
but uh yeah i'll get to that in a moment
jb
so not g4 we can just take the knight
actually we can take the knight
and if he takes f5 then we take the rook
and we win the queen
so how did i know well it's look it's
hard for me to
fully explain exactly like how i knew
that sacrificing is good that's what
intuition is
sort of by definition intuition is hard
to put into words it's just a gut
feeling that this is gonna work
but i explained some of the factors that
i think contribute to my subconscious
gut feeling and one of them is i have at
least two pawns for the piece
which really lowers the stakes like even
if this fails
right i'm probably gonna have three
pawns for the piece which materially
speaking is enough compensation
but the other thing is is the
combination of the fact that i have a
lot of pieces in the attack and
potentially also the knight
so one two three potentially the roclet
four right this bishop could come in
five
black's pieces are extremely cramped and
they will remain cramped
uh for the foreseeable future i mean how
is black gonna get his pieces out
quickly
and so all of these things put together
right even without calculating
a variation other than knight f5 bishop
takes f5 i'm able to kind of tell with a
reasonable degree of certainty
that white is winning here it's plus
seven actually asteroid delta gifting to
matthew thank you so much
for the gift itself no i would that's
the best move actually i think
knight g5 is the best move according to
the computer yep it's the best move
so you know we played accurately here
now
i think what you should have done in
this position is
basically bitten the bullet this is not
an easy position to play but i would
have gone
maybe b6 maybe just develop honestly
bishop d7
and when you're cramped like this what
you sometimes want to do to annoy your
opponent is
literally just like nothing right you do
what you can to develop your pieces
and if white goes knight to b3
how do you prevent the knight from
getting to c5
and attacking e6 like is there a way to
prevent that
well e5 doesn't work that's why we piled
up our pieces on the e5 square
yeah so we can play b6 now if you're
playing white how can you
undermine the b6 upon slight change of
plans
we wanted to go b5 but that is no longer
necessary
radcliffe another gifted to remye we can
go a5
and the fact that black's pawn is on a6
actually hurts you
so dialing the logic back i would not
play a6 here for that specific reason i
would go
b6 immediately or maybe bishop d7 first
knight b3 and then b6
because now if white goes a4 and a5 you
don't have to do anything you can ignore
this
which means that you're not going to be
able to get the knights of c5 and black
black's position holds here it's not
easy for white to actually break through
black's defenses
if black sort of defends this very
calmly if that makes sense so i think
the move a6 as tempting as it is to try
to stop b5
it's actually a mistake this move is
actually a mistake precisely because
now it's going to be very hard to stop
the knight from coming to c5
does that make sense so so the move b5
here doesn't work a takes b5
and and rook takes rock what about b5
after b6 well the the thing is um
if you go oh you mean bishop d7 knight
b3 b6 yeah b5 is annoying
but you could go either knight a yeah
you could go knight a5 here i get that
like this ruins the structure but
hey you have to accept some some
deficiencies also this opens up the c
file and black stroke could target this
backward pawn on c3 thank you drink the
dead
um so you know we're not going to delve
too deeply into this position white
basically is going to try to break
through maybe
h4 h5 uh black is worse but but the
position certainly remains defensible
and basically after the sacrifice is
done we just
break through you know and now knight d
takes e4 that's kind of the chemo both
knights are hanging
but neither can be captured because if d
takes c4 then we play bishop c4 chuck
if king f8 we can check mate in a nice
way with knight h7
and if knight t5 then the queen is
overloaded it has two jobs
defend the rook defend the night hey i
can't do both the same time
either you take the bishop and you lose
control of the rook disaster or
you don't take the bishop and you get
checkmated so
it's all very simple here you can kind
of position kind of plays itself
if you take the other knight then of
course knight takes g5 with with all
sorts of threats here and
just absolutely crushing this there's
just no way black can possibly defend
uh and and i hope that makes sense yeah
i mean the turning point might have even
been e6 right
the turning point might have even been
e6 because this really makes black's
position hard to play
this is just too passive and and
honestly i think i played a really nice
game i think
you know we played a really nice game i
think i think um
you know and i'm not taking it easy on
anybody here so don't feel bad about it
i'm really i'm playing my full strength
here
uh so so certainly don't feel 98.8
so i don't feel bad about losing don't
feel bad about it being a one-sided game
you're doing a great deed by putting
yourself out there and allowing me
the the privilege of playing you and
explaining all the moves